[Musique]
êtes-vous sûr de vouloir faire ça, ce n'est
pas ce que je veux que l'
honneur exige
tellement si cette scène parle de ce qui
se passe avant et de la montée de la
tension entre les fils et l'aria dans les
épisodes précédents de la saison où vous
croyez vraiment celui-là  va potentiellement
tuer l'autre, c'est l'un des avantages
de travailler sur une émission comme celle-ci où, au
fil des ans, tant de
personnages ont été tués et tant de
personnages prennent des décisions que vous souhaiteriez qu'ils
n'aient pas que vous pouvez croire que Sansa
pourrait conspirer  contre Artie conscient que
Daria pourrait décider que Sansa a
trahi la famille et mérite de mourir en
sachant que vous visez que cela a
vraiment aidé à l'écrire
parce que le seul but et ces scènes
sont de construire vers ce qui ressemble à une
véritable faille  entre eux d'une manière qui le
rend extrêmement difficile lorsque vous entrez
dans cette pièce avec eux à la fin, comment
répondez-vous à ces accusations Lord Baelish
J'étais en fait très intéressé et
excité de voir ce que  Aidan ferait avec
ce moment parce que c'est un moment dans lequel il
n'a jamais été avant d'
avoir imaginé toutes les
éventualités imaginables sauf celle-ci, les dames
doivent me pardonner, je suis un peu confus
quoi que vous vouliez dire à propos de
Littlefinger et il est clairement un
sociopathe entre autres choses  il
a des sentiments forts envers Sansa,
ce ne sont pas nécessairement
des sentiments appropriés sains mais ce sont des
sentiments envers elle et donc je pense qu'il
a du mal à croire qu'elle
pourra faire ce coucher de soleil s'il vous plaît allez
tout droit Ilona
mais je sais malheureusement pour  lui, il l'a
trop bien entraînée et elle n'est pas
sur le point d'être influencée par ses larmes ou ses
supplications merci pour toutes vos nombreuses
leçons Lord Baelish
[Musique]
vous avez plus de 60 heures à ce stade de
personnages principaux dans lesquels vous, espérons-le, êtes
vraiment investi  c'était un défi
parce qu'il y avait tellement de façons différentes de
procéder, mais le fait qu'il était
centré sur l'effort de persuader
Cersei de se retirer et d'accepter une
trêve  cela lui a donné une colonne vertébrale,
il ne s'agit pas de vivre en harmonie, il s'agit
simplement de vivre, il y a tellement d'
interconnexions différentes entre toutes
ces personnes.
Turn the Hound n'est
pas quelqu'un qui va laisser cette personne
ou chose ou quoi qu'il soit maintenant marcher à côté de
lui sans contestation étant donné qui la montagne
est pour lui et a été pour lui dans sa
vie vous savez qui vient pour vous
vous avez presque connu l'un des  les thèmes de
la saison selon lesquels les personnages pourraient être
sceptiques à propos de la religion et du
surnaturel, mais une fois qu'ils l'affrontent
face à un visage en décomposition, il est vraiment
difficile de le nier plus
je ne peux plus servir deux reines alors il n'y a plus
rien à discuter
je ne relie pas Aryan va  voir Cersei à
une fierté ou prouver qu'il viole ganas l'
une des situations où c'est le
seul choix qu'il peut voir c'est la seule façon
qu'il ressent une récupération de chaleur cette
mission de paix est d'aller lui  moi-même, il est la seule
personne qui peut lui parler parce
qu'autant qu'elle le déteste et autant qu'il la
déteste, ils se connaissent
mieux que probablement n'importe qui dans le
monde les connaît, je me fiche de
vérifier mes pires impulsions.  Je ne me soucie
pas de rendre le monde meilleur
et le monde est un peu
ringard et ils jouent là-bas parce
qu'il semble qu'elle bluffe et qu'il
lit son Bluff mais elle voulait qu'il
lise son bluff tout cela faisait partie d'elle
jeu
tu seras enceinte Cersei est devenue assez
douée pour jouer à ce jeu, elle n'était pas au
pouvoir mais elle était à la limite du pouvoir
et elle a appris à fonctionner dans cet
environnement et elle l'a placé ici
assez joliment ici l'obscurité
arrive pour  nous tous, nous allons y faire face ensemble,
nous sommes dans cette fosse aux dragons pendant de nombreux
jours, c'est une chose aussi difficile
à filmer parce qu'il y a tellement de
moments différents entre différentes
personnes et ils doivent être filmés de cette
façon sinon ça n'a pas l'air  quelconque  le corps
regarde la personne qu'il est
censé regarder ou jouer avec la personne
qu'il est censé jouer nous avons
tous les deux vu ce qui vient de se passer cela va
au-delà des maisons et de l'honneur et des serments c'est
un moment intéressant pour Brielle
parce que Brienne est tellement définie  par loyauté,
mais cela va au-delà du fait que parler à la
reine
Jaime est choisi pour se ranger du côté de sa sœur,
elle est sans équivoque mauvaise, tout le monde le sait,
y compris Jaime, elle essaie juste
de lui faire voir au-delà de cela, cela en dit
beaucoup, je pense que c'est certainement dans l'esprit de Jamie
mais  alors la goutte d'eau finale est quand il se
rend compte que tout cela n'était qu'une arnaque J'ai
toujours su que tu étais le plus stupide ensuite
Je pense que voir la vérité sur ce qu'il y a dans
le nord cela signifiait une chose pour Jaime
et cela signifiait autre chose pour Cersei
ils ont tous deux reconnu la vérité  de cela,
ils sont tous les deux assez intelligents pour comprendre
ce que cela signifie, mais elle le voit toujours
d'un point de vue stratégique froid et
il le voit du point de vue plus de
la survie existentielle pour toujours  yone à
propos des maisons nobles c'est à propos des
vivants et des morts
et j'ai l'intention de rester parmi les vivants
c'est une chose à dire d'accord sérieusement
joué un tour à ses ennemis mais elle
ne s'est pas confiée à lui alors il se rend compte
que sa loyauté envers elle est  ne se reflète pas
dans sa loyauté envers lui et on
me regarde bien Je pense que c'est absolument
ce qui informe sa décision de quitter
King's Landing Je ne crois pas
[Musique]
il a besoin de connaître la vérité la vérité
sur ce qui le concerne
John n'est pas John  Sam, il est en fait la
marque qui a enfin entendu parler de Liana
Aegon Targaryen et cela signifie qu'il est l'
héritier légitime du trône de fer qui
change tout, je dirais que le
défi avec cette séquence était de trouver
un moyen de présenter des informations qu'au
moins une bonne partie du public
avait déjà d'une manière dramatique
et excitante avait également un nouvel élément une
partie de la réponse à la façon de
faire cela était dans la nature entrecoupée du montage
il s'agissait de le rendre
cl  entendre que c'était presque comme une
bombe d'information que John se dirigeait
vers ce que monsieur construisait dans un
mensonge, la seule façon de vraiment souligner
cela était de lier ces deux mondes
ensemble cinématographiquement et d'avoir du son
racontant réellement ces faits sur les
images de John  et de Danny c'est l'
héritier du Trône de Fer au moment où on
voit ces deux personnes se rapprocher
on entend l'information qui va
inévitablement sinon les déchirer du
moins causer de vrais problèmes dans leur
relation et c'est sa tante ça
complique tout  au niveau politique au
niveau personnel et cela
rend tout ce qui aurait pu être si
soigné et parfait pour John et
Danny et cela brouille vraiment les eaux dont
nous avons besoin pour lui dire
[Musique]
nous avons essayé de contraster les différentes saisons se
terminant ainsi  qu'ils ne se sentent pas trop
similaires, donc la saison dernière, nous avons eu une
fin assez triomphale avec Danny
naviguant finalement vers l'ouest en direction de Westeros, celui-ci
est définitivement beaucoup plus horrible
des années maintenant, nous savons que ce serait la
fin de l'avant-dernière saison, les
murs ont gardé ces choses à l'écart pendant 8000
ans où il n'y a aucune raison réelle pour qu'il
ne puisse pas continuer à le faire à moins que
quelque chose ne fasse un trou dans un mur, il y a
une chose sur le  tableau depuis le
début qui est maintenant assez grand pour faire
ça et c'est un dragon
qu'ils commencent juste à se proposer comme une
voie logique à suivre, nous écrivons, puis
le mur s'effondre et c'est
vraiment facile de taper ces travailleurs c'est
euh c'est vraiment difficile pour  pour que ça ait l'
air bien, il
fallait que ce soit une chose que vous sortez de la
saison les quatre ou cinq premières années de
la série, c'était l'univers en expansion
et à l'approche de la fin de la série,
les personnages des contrats de l'univers
vont dans un endroit qui  ils n'ont jamais eu
auparavant littéralement et puis dans certains
cas, mais aussi juste un sens plus large où
ils sont confrontés aux conflits dont ils savent qu'ils
décideront de leur sort
le loup solitaire meurt mais les packs de glace l'
hiver est là et tout est frappé  ting the
fan from all directions
[Music]
Game of Thrones a Caesar mis sur l'
exclusivité Yosemite ne nous a jamais plu
COCs Ljubica stop of cinema silly
[Music]
Lucy is it was it fun you see ennemis à
l'est ennemis à l'ouest ennemis
au sud ennemis  au nord, peu importe ce qui
se dresse sur notre chemin, nous vaincrons les
Lannister
Je suis né pour gouverner les Sept Royaumes
et je le
ferai  de côté nos inimitiés et
liés ensemble nous mourrons
et peu importe dont le
squelette est assis sur le Trône de Fer
[Musique]
la Grande Muraille est-il